The number of stars in the universe is quite uncountable.
Their number in the observable part of space may be upwards of a Alion.
Although the idea of actually arriving at an exact value is hardly feasible
either now or indeed at any point in the future today's point in question is
not stars, but largest structures. They make up.
As we know Stella systems together with their rarefied gas and dark matter
formed gravitationally bowed structures called galaxy,
according to different estimates,
mankind is currently able to observe several hundred billion of them in
different stages of their revolution.
Let's talk about some of the most unusual ones,
Cosmo, the first and outer space
distances from the Milky way to other galaxies are by all accounts,
mind boggling as a rule.
It is anything from millions to billions of light years due to the universe's
cosmological expansion.
The distance between the earth and any remote object in the universe is
constantly growing,
which makes the light emanating from this object lure than it actually is.
This phenomenon is known as a Redshift. It is of great help engaging distances,
and Velocitys on the astronomical scale. Alternatively,
some galaxies spectrum is blue shifted,
which may means that they're not on an escape trajectory from us,
but on the contrary are moving to meet us.
One of these unusual space objects is the galaxy M 86 in the
Virgo cluster, roughly 52 million light years away from the sun.
It is moving towards the Milky way at a speed of around 244
kilometers. Second,
which makes it one of the fastest moving blue shifted galaxies
by moving to high speed through the scattered gas,
the Virgo cluster is filled with M 86 is costly shedding its own inter Stella
matter. As a result of this process,
it leaves a trail of long lines of warm ironized hydrogen behind
M eight is six is connected with the am,
almost destroyed spiral galaxy and GC 44 38 with several of these
filaments.
These two galaxies are thought to have collided at some point in the distant
past, which was the smaller ones undoing.
Interestingly M eight is six is known to have destroyed its other are neighbors
in the past as well.
Several stellar streams have been detected in its halo that are likely to be the
remains of smaller galaxies absorbed earlier.
An impressive number of globular clusters in its structure is another
outstanding feature of M 86 observations show that their number is
upwards of 3,800, which is around 25 times.
As many is in the Milky way.
There is a theory that claims these clusters to be the remains of dwarf
galaxies. The TA 86 would've absorbed in the past.
If it truly is the case,
then it would've destroyed tens or even hundreds of other galaxies.
Having said that M 86 Luke Santa thing, but unique.
The galaxy ESO 1 37 dash one,
which will be looking at next has a similar shape, but unlike M 86,
it appears more outlandishly, original
located 227 million light years away from the sun.
It is as heavy as five to 14 billion solar masses as for its
stars. Most of them are young and bright blue giants here.
So 1 37 dash one in its turn is part of a bell
36, 27, a large galaxy plus
moving to its center at an incredible speed of almost 2000 kilometers per
second. The galaxy collides with inter style gas pressure inside the cluster.
As a result, its own gas is blown out,
leaving behind tails at stretch for up to 200 as 60,000 light years.
Incidentally,
the massive Intella gas in those areas is due to four times out of the gas
inside the galaxy.
It is hardly surprising that Starbursts are a common thing here that is stars.
Don't stop forming in these enormous streams made up mostly of hydrogen when
seen from the side E so 1 37 dash one appear like
a giant jellyfish floating Threadless expanses of space.
Unfortunately as the galaxies continuously stripped of its Interstella gas,
its life expectancy diminishes too,
with not much material left known new stars can form here,
which greatly affects the structure of the spiral arms and central BGE of the
Galax. See, on the bright side,
scientists have a chance of finding out more about dark matter and its
interaction with other space objects.
By observing the behavior of the gas streams left in the galaxy. Wake
speaking about the formation of newest stars.
There is a galaxy with a name that speaks for itself, baby boom,
around 4,000 stars are born here every year,
which is about 400 times more than in the Milky way.
Straightforward calculations show that on average and new star lights up in this
area of space, every two hours,
the baby boom galaxy lies around 12.2 billion light years away.
The earth.
This means that what we see when observing it is what was happening just one and
half billion years after the hypothetical big bang,
it was a time when the universe was still in the process of forming its
structure.
What is taking place in the galaxy now is drastically different from what we
expect to observe there. In theory, based on,
on what we know about star formation,
the reasons why stars are produced here at such an astounding rate and not known
yet,
but it is beyond any doubt that baby boom is able to provide us with a lot of
information about the early stages of our universe's evolution.
One of the few galaxies one can observe through an amateur telescope is the
so-called sombrero galaxy official designation, M 1 0 4,
it lies 30 million light years away from the sun.
And its diameter is roughly four times smaller than that, of the Milky away
sombrero Galaxy's outstanding feature is a massive ring of dust and cold
hydrogen enveloping it observations show that it is here that most young stars
are born. In addition to the peculiar ring,
the sombrero galaxy is also remarkable for its elaborate in a makeup
observations with a spit space telescope show that most stars in this
galaxy form, a structure typical of elliptical galaxies.
The stars here are mostly rather old, yellow and red wars.
The other stars here on the other hand form spiral structures concealed within
an elliptical cloud.
It is thought that this phenomenon is a result of two galaxies collision with
their stars subsequently and D inevitably mingling together.
It is incredible that the galactic structures survived a emerge of that scale
with minimal damage are none the worst for this tremendous collision and can
still be observed another peculiar featuring the sombrero galaxy
is exceptionally powerful. X-ray radiation emanating from the center.
It is assumed that the Cresent disc of a super massive black hole may be its
source. The mass of the hole is estimated to be over a billion solar masses,
which makes this enormous object.
One of the most massive black holes known to science today.
There are also several sources of tremendously high frequency, Tara Hertz,
radiation detected within the galaxy.
Although today their nature is still a mystery.
Our gala galactic parade today is concluded with yet another object boasting,
an elaborate in a structure,
the Erie M 64 galaxy rather aptly dubbed the black eye
galaxy,
the nickname car from a dark band of cosmic dust that partly conceals the
Galaxy's center from the observer on the earth due to this line of cosmic dust,
as well as the exceptionally bright active nucleus.
It is impossible to estimate the black eyes number of stars.
Even roughly what we do know is that it is comparatively small and not
so remote it's ideas measures 25,000 light years,
and it lies approximately 17 million light years away from the Milky way.
The black eye galaxy is made up of two well defined parts. Interestingly,
the inner disk with a bulge rotate in the direction opposite to that of the
outer ring.
The most light likely explanation for such a bizarre makeup is that the galaxy
formed after two smaller ones collided and merged in the distant past,
admittedly,
it would take a combination of a number of mutually independent factors for such
a fascinating and well defined structure to form. For example,
the progenitor galaxies would've moved its specific velocities and come together
at a certain angle. The odds of a success would've been minuscule.
The universe shows a rich diversity of hundreds of billions, of galaxies,
consisting of downright,
countless hours of all makes and sizes from tiny dwarves to super giants
among these. They are countless amazing and unique worlds all together.
They constitute our wonderful and mysterious universe.
If you feel like learning more about it, subscribe to our channel,
if you still haven't done so,
and look out for our new and hopefully awesome videos, let's keep in touch.